ROBERT KUBIS: In this episode
of "Things-I-Learned About Cloud
Spanner," we look at
write-batching to help
a database specialist
accelerate their data load.
Will we find the
right strategies
for higher throughputs?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the previous episode,
I helped my friend Anna,
and her company,
Pile Of Gadgets,
an online shop for gadget fans.
We were able to solve
a hotspotting issue
during the data load that
kept the throughput low
and the Cloud Spanner
instance under-utilized.
By choosing new,
well-distributed primary keys
for the tables,
we saw an increase
in throughput and utilization.
Now we are going to see if
we can improve the data load
performance even further.
The data load app, which reads
the records from csv files
and writes them
to Cloud Spanner,
was writing only one
row per transaction.
Since our goal is to load
data as fast as possible,
loading with a single
row per transaction
doesn't sound like
the optimal solution.
It seemed obvious
to batch as many
writes as possible together to
see a considerable throughput
boost, while staying below
transaction limits, of course.
The records we were
loading are fairly small,
so we increased the batch size
to 1,000 rows per transaction,
and expected much
higher throughputs
due to the reduced client-server
communications and transaction
overhead.
Surprisingly, we
only saw a bit more
than doubling of our
write throughput--
50,000 rows instead of
the previous 20,000 rows
per second.
Don't get me wrong--
more than doubling the
throughput is great.
But we wanted to see if we
can improve this even further.
As it turns out, we were
still missing a step
to get the real
benefits of batching.
The rows that were
batched together
have well-distributed
primary keys,
the ones we introduced
in the previous episode
to fix the hotspotting
issue during data load.
That means writing
1,000 of those rows
with well-distributed primary
keys in a single transaction
ends up involving many,
many table splits.
As you know, a table is
split based on size and load
patterns in ranges of rows
ordered alphabetically
by primary key.
The responsibility
for the split is then
distributed among the
available compute nodes,
where each split is controlled
by exactly one node.
Now, when we write to multiple
splits in a single transaction,
Cloud Spanner
needs to coordinate
between all the nodes that are
responsible for these splits.
For that, it needs to obtain
locks and serialize the access
for all outstanding transactions
writing to any of these splits,
using the two-phase
commit protocol.
This means the
benefits of having
multiple rows in one
transaction are reduced
by coordination
overhead incurred
by spanning multiple splits.
Armed with this knowledge of
the inner workings of Cloud
Spanner, we needed a way to
reduce the number of splits
accessed by each transaction
to gain the maximum benefit
of batching.
We went back to
our loader program
and modified it to load a large
number of rows into cache.
We then sorted these rows
alphabetically by primary key--
the same way the table
splits are ordered--
and partitioned them by
our chosen batch size.
From there, we created
one transaction
for each of the partitions.
Some might ask here,
didn't we just introduce
well-distributed
primary keys to avoid
hotspotting in the
previous episode,
and now we are sorting?
Right.
The trick here is that
the ordered partitions
are distinct in the primary
key ranges they write to.
Spanning fewer table splits
ensues, causing less contention
during writes.
As you can see in
the graph, this
improved our load
performance significantly,
to about 120,000 rows per
second, a six-fold increase
to where we started from.
Now, to find the optimal
load performance,
we have to keep a couple
of limitations in mind.
Besides optimal size
ranges for transactions,
between 1 to 10 megabytes,
there is a strict limitation
of 20,000 mutation
per transaction.
Mutation?
What is that?
A mutation has a
special meaning here,
where any modification of a
single cell in a table or index
accounts for one
mutation, except if you
delete a range of rows.
So for example, if you have
a table with five columns,
and an index defined on
three of those columns,
including the primary key
columns, each instance of a row
accounts for eight mutations.
Now, if you don't want
to write all this logic
into your own data loader,
you can use the Cloud Dataflow
connector for Cloud Spanner.
The connector does the
sorting, partitioning,
and scaling out writes
automatically for you.
Check out the sample source code
we linked in the description
to learn more about it.
After all these data
load optimizations,
my friend's company,
Pile of Gadgets,
was now happy with
the load performance,
and started to look
into how to optimize
the apps for scalability
and performance.
Unfortunately, we are out
of time in this episode.
So stay tuned for
our next one, where
we show how to design our
transactions for scalability
and performance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]